good afternoon everyone
i'm happy to be here
at the headquarters of nato for the
first time
as canada's minister of national defense
i've just met with
the secretary general
we discussed the situation in ukraine
we also discussed canada's contribution
to nato
finally we discussed arctic sovereignty
and the importance of arctic sovereignty
for the security
of canada north america
and the broader
worldwide security situation
i'm happy to answer your questions good
afternoon my name is mark from
associated press last i heard canada had
about 200 troops in ukraine
how are you feeling right now is that
enough troops for what your mission is
uh do you feel like maybe more
troops are in the future
well thank you for the question
last wednesday we committed to expanding
and extending our current operation in
ukraine which consists of 200 troops or
so on the ground we committed to
increasing our capacity to 400 troops
with 60 troops leaving in the coming
days
from canada
we also
committed 340 million dollars to
expanding that mission
as well as additional forms of aid and
support
for cyber security and cyber
surveillance
so our approach to ukraine is strong
stable and methodical we have been on
the ground there since 2015 and we will
continue to support the international
rules-based order in a strong secure and
sovereign ukraine
we are continually examining our
contribution not only in ukraine but
also under operation reassurance which
has
approximately 900 canadian armed forces
able to be deployed to central and
eastern europe we currently are
also
making sure that from a global strategic
standpoint we are able to be supporting
our
obligations to nato the international
rules based order as well as the
territorial integrity of ukraine this is
an ongoing situation this did not start
in november 2021
since the russian invasion of crimea in
2014 canada has been committed we
started with operation unifier we also
in addition to those military issues and
approaches that i just outlined
committed 120 million dollars of a loan
as well as 50 million dollars in
economic and humanitarian aid last week
so in other words our support for
ukraine is ongoing it's comprehensive
but we will continue to examine the
situation as it evolves
nato is
reinforcing its eastern border what's
the purpose of that right now
well the most important
piece of information that we should
all recognize is that there has been
an increasing presence of russian troops
along that eastern border
and as well as the border with belarus
and the importance of a strong
nato
commitment at the current time
is undeniable why because
at the current time
nato is being tested
and it is incumbent upon all of us as
nato members
to
ensure that we are doing our part
for the protection of a strong secure
and stable
ukraine is an answer from the from
russia on the answer from nato and uh on
the contract of nato and the u.s
um what's your first impression of the
reaction of the russian zone
impression is that at the current time
russia has an important
choice to make
it can choose to negotiate with a view
to de-escalation
or it can face
harsh economic sanctions
that is the choice on the table
that is what needs to be addressed at
the current time we are all very much
hoping for a diplomatic solution and
that is
something that is now in russia's court
to decide
what's your assessment of the
chances of the russian invasion of
ukraine
at the current time as i mentioned
we are hoping for a diplomatic solution
but at the same time we do need to
prepare for all eventualities
and what that has meant from a canadian
perspective
is that we have moved the canadian armed
forces
to
the west of the dinipro river
and we have undertaken some evacuation
of non-essential staff and families from
our embassy
at the same time
we are committing
to support ukraine
with additional trainers on the ground
with non-lethal equipment
with financial aid
and so you can see that the security of
ukraine and the stability of ukraine in
this very concerning and very fluid
moment is top of mind for me as minister
of national defense
as well as for our country
it has begun to arrive already
and in terms of what difference it will
make let me lay out for you what some of
this aid consists of and then you'll be
able to see for yourself
how important it would be surveillance
equipment night vision equipment goggles
mobile hospitals
equipment that would be used in the case
of detonation of explosives
these are all very important aspects of
ensuring
preparedness and canada stands ready to
support with this non-lethal aid
and as i said it has begun to arrive
already in
the black sea ukraine
canada will do its part as a member of
nato as well as on a bilateral basis to
support the international rules-based
order which has been in place since the
end of the second world war we make no
mistake that at the current time there
is a very threatening situation at the
border at the same time we need to
ensure that
we recognize that operation unifier is a
training mission
we are
and have been training russian uh
ukrainian soldiers for the past seven
years how many
over 30 000 ukrainian soldiers have been
trained by the canadian armed forces
including 2 000
members of the ukrainian national guard
if you think about that type of
contribution
and the longevity of it in terms of
ukraine's preparedness
i think that you will
hopefully come to the realization that
it is significant
[Music]
[Music]
concerning liquid by natural gas
does canada have more to offer europe
because europe is looking also for
energy security
as minister of national defense my role
has primarily been in the support that
the canadian armed forces can offer
ukraine at this time i know that my
colleague minister jolie and
minister freeland are both working on a
number of additional options together
with our government
including the various ones that you
mentioned last question
have you been in contact with russia
since lincoln sent the answers of the
united states on the questionnaire of
russia
actually my focus has been on ensuring a
strong and
stable alliance in response to the very
concerning situation in ukraine i have
spoken with a number of my nato
colleagues
including the united states the united
kingdom
spain
portugal denmark
and canada's role
is to be
a bridge builder from a transatlantic
perspective
in terms of solidifying
the
very important
support
for ukraine in this particular moment in
time it is a role that we have
historically played and it is a role
that we will continue to play and i look
forward to coming back to brussels in
two weeks for a meeting of defense
ministers where we will continue this
very important conversation but make no
mistake canada stands ready to continue
to support and uphold the international
rules-based order and the territorial
integrity of ukraine
thank you